Leadership support for more perfect
is provided by the Joyce Foundation.
This is more perfect series about the
supreme court. I'm Jed up and Rod.
In February of 2017 Supreme Court,
Justice Ruth Bader Ginsburg said
something that surprised a lot of people.
Well,
I would say that we are not
experiencing the best of times.
She stepped straight into the political
fray and addressed this political
moment.
It was a great man.
Once said that the true symbol of the
United States is not the Bald Eagle.
It is the
pendulum,
and when the pendulum swings
too far in one direction,
it will go back.
Some terrible things have happened in
the United States that one can only hope
that we learn from those bad things.
Today we're going to ride the
pendulum to the dark side.
I'm going to start with one of the most
infamous decisions the court has ever
made. The Korematsu decision, right?
You might imagine it's not going
to be the happiest of situations,
but the story that we're going to tell
you today and tomorrow as well, actually,
they're not stories,
a bitterness because this curious
thing happens in both cases when our
characters can't find justice
inside the Supreme Court,
you stop looking for it there.
Okay.
And they find it somewhere else entirely.
Producer Julia Longoria starts us off.
[inaudible]
the year is 1967 and the place is San
Lorenzo high school in the East Bay of
California.
No school day.
We're in a US history classroom.
I was actually a junior in high
school. This is Karen Korematsu.
I'm the executive director and founder
of the Fred t Komatsu Institute in San
Francisco. So on this particular day,
Karen is sitting at the back
of the classroom and our
teacher had assigned each
of my classmates a little
paperback book to read, you know,
books about American history, government.
And the assignment was to then get up
in front of the class and give an oral
book report. I mean
this is a long time ago.
So that's the way they used to do
things. I don't even remember what my,
my book was or my subject, but,
but Karen said she was just sitting
there in class listening as one by one.
Her classmates got up,
talked about George Washington
or Abraham Lincoln or whatever.
And then my friend Maya,
who is a Japanese American
third generation like myself,
got up in front of the class and her
book was called Concentration Camps USA,
about the Japanese American
internment. And I thought,
no, that's interesting. I hadn't heard
about that before. What's that? About?
Maya's book report when
something like this
in 1941 divided states
of America was attack
and the president, President Roosevelt
as commander in chief had to respond.
I have to erect it, let him all the
measure eyes be taken. [inaudible]
so in terms of defense,
one of the big questions for Roosevelt
was what happens if the Japanese
[inaudible]
fade? The continental us
America sounding on a long,
they'd probably come in on the west
coast and you had more than a hundred
thousand Japanese Americans
living on the west coast.
Like would they turn against the
United States? They didn't know.
And so her friend Maya
explained to them [inaudible]
class on February 19th,
1942 President Roosevelt issued
executive order nine oh six six that gave
the military the authority to forcibly
remove any one of Japanese ancestry from
the west coast,
said as soon as an aliens or
like what happened to move.
She goes on to explain these,
the horrific circumstances
and how you know,
120,000 people of Japanese
ancestry had been, you know,
forcibly removed from their homes.
She explained they were put into these
detention camps really without any due
process of law. But
then she went on to say,
but there was this one man who refused
to go to the camps and he was arrested
and he sued the government and took his
case all the way to the supreme court.
And then he became LM
Mark's Poom court case.
And that man's name is Fred Korematsu. Oh,
I said to myself, that's my name.
She says the class got really quiet and
I had 35 pairs eyes turned around and
looking at me. Okay. Yes. She
thought my last name is Corp Matsu.
My Dad's name is Fred, but no
way. There's no way it's my dad.
Someone would've told me. So of course,
and I go running home and
confronting my mother and asking her,
what does she say? Well, I got
the standard to answer, uh,
wait until your father gets home and
you can ask him that voice you heard.
By the way, it was Ellie, Ms Doll or
legal editor. And by the time he, uh,
had got home, it was eight
o'clock in the evening.
And so that's a long time after,
you know, three 30 in the afternoon.
And I calmed down a little bit and
I asked him and, and he said, uh,
it happened a long time
ago. And what he did,
he thought was right and
the government was wrong
and it was at clear and simple.
I could just see this hurt going over
his face and I just couldn't ask him any
more questions. Karen says,
it wasn't until years later that she
learned what really happened and why her
dad never wanted to talk about it.
Well, I was a 21 then.
This is Fred Korematsu. It's tape
of him from the denture archives
and I was up on the hill Sunday
morning, but my girlfriend
and Fred story starts out on a date.
You know when you're that age,
you know you have a girlfriend
just like anybody else.
And then she was more
important to me than anything.
Fred and his girlfriend, Ida,
are driving in the hills above San
Francisco looking down on the city,
the Golden Gate Bridge. He'd been
dating this girl for a while now. She,
she was Caucasian, Italian American.
Most of his friends were Caucasian
and we were in a car and we were
deciding what to do with such a nice day.
Either go picnicking or something like
that. And then all of a sudden I heard,
yeah,
we interrupt this program to bring you
a special newest product to the Japanese
attacked Pearl Harbor. Hawaii bite,
eh brother than rose has Justin.
He came on the air and your car radio
calm without electrifying.
No little crowds right now gather
to the front of the White House,
State Department and the
company then. But the,
and I was quite shocked.
Both were,
Fred knew there was a war on and that
the U S was likely to get involved.
He'd even tried to enlist
in the u s military,
but was denied because he was Japanese
American and he said, sitting there,
one of his first thoughts was, why
does it have to be Japan? Okay?
Some country was going to
attack the alarm, Bro. I
wish it was Russia. You know,
I just thought about that. You know,
I was better with Japan
to having this happen.
So I took her home and then I went home
[inaudible]
so he gets home.
My parents were all shocked.
They were all sitting
around the living room.
The house is just in
despair. His mom is in tears.
They were proud of being Japanese,
you know, they obeyed the law.
They did everything that supposed
to, and then to have this happen,
it put them in shame. It was even
hard to talk to them after that.
Fred had a traditional immigrant,
Japanese American family.
His parents were born in Japan,
and then all his brothers were born here
in the u s born in Oakland, California.
He was the third out of four
brothers and being the third,
not the second or the first
that mattered. Absolutely.
Fred was an innate position as
the third son. He could resist.
We asked Lorraine Banai,
I teach at Seattle University
School of law for some context.
She's a law professor and a friend of
Fred's family. The cultural tradition
is that the first son is the favored son.
The oldest was going to inherit the
family garden and nursery business.
The second would help out with that
business. Fred as the third son,
was very low on the totem pole.
His parents didn't have the same
expectations of him, relatively speaking.
He was kind of off the hook.
Unlike his older brothers,
he didn't speak much Japanese and he
felt more American than anything else.
When I was in school, we started each
day with the pledge of allegiance.
I studied American history. I've
always been a good American citizen.
So when he came home that Sunday
when Pearl Harbor was attacked,
his family's response to the
whole thing was unsettling. I, um,
I didn't know what to do.
And Fred says pretty soon
after things got very weird.
Within a few days they put spotlights on
the whole nursery at night and they had
a guard standing right here in our
home there round. We're on the fence,
they're watching us cause I went out
one night to have a cigarette and I were
standing on a part and I lit
a cigarette and a guard. Yeah,
bother. If I was signaling
somebody, they're ridiculous.
Then came Roosevelt's executive order.
Okay,
big order nine oh six six authorize the
military to make a series of smaller
ones. The first set of orders was a curfew
order saying that Japanese, Italian,
and German, this were
subject to her curfew.
The second order was a freeze order
directed just at the Japanese on the west
coast.
They weren't allowed to leave the area
and then the third order wasn't ordered
that they could not remain on the west
coast except for in the custody of an
approved location by the army.
All persons of Japanese descent
were required to move with them.
There were about 15 of these assembly
centers and Japanese Americans were told
to report to one of these
centers by a certain date.
Native evacuation notice came,
Fred's family began to scramble.
They had the worry about
what they were going to take,
what was going to happen to the nursery.
So especially when my mother, you know,
the tension and worries. So in
the days before his family left,
Fred made a decision. Me being
the third son, you know, I,
um, I had my own worries. I had
mom, girlfriend mio and problems.
He decided not to go with his family.
I, um, talked to them that, uh,
that I didn't want to leave.
I won't leave with you.
You didn't want to leave
Ida behind any thought.
Maybe the two of them could
make a break for it later on.
Leave the state before
the evacuation deadline.
And, um, they said, fine,
if you can do it, go ahead.
He was the third son.
So he knew that his older brothers would
be able to take care of the family and
they said he was a grownup and he should
make his own decisions. And so he did.
He went off and got his own apartment
and his own job as a welder and kind of
lived under the radar.
He knew his brothers would be
there to take care of his parents.
If you're with a family, like my
family or any Japanese family,
you feel the pressure and the sadness
[inaudible]
but on the outside is definitely
just like a normal wipe, you know?
Just like we've been living all the time.
Yeah.
I felt right at home, you
know as well. I had got,
I'm an American citizen too, you know?
[inaudible]
I didn't feel guilty because I
don't think I did anything wrong.
No ma'am.
Do you have a sense that he was
politically aware at this point?
If you're asking me about whether he
refused to go as an act of political
resistance, I don't think initially,
unconsciously he probably knew that what
was happening to Japanese Americans was
wrong, but I don't think he had the
words for it that we might have today.
[inaudible]
it's on his way home from work.
One day that he reads in the newspaper
about his parents and all the other
Japanese Americans in the
area. Being taken away to camp
made me sick to my stomach, you
know, I can see my parents going in,
you know, and my brother's
climbed into camp and uh,
I'm not there, you know,
but that was the only time that I felt
kind of lonely, you know, like, well,
what am I going to do now? You know,
it begins to slowly dawn on him what
he's done by staying in the bay area.
He is officially breaking the law and
he and Ida aren't sure what that means.
Like will they be thrown in jail or worse?
He talks in the archives about how he's
worried and Ida's worry too because now
he could get arrested. So they
start to think about their options.
Fred decides to get an ID with a Spanish
sounding last name on it so we won't be
recognized as Japanese. And then Ida says,
essentially that might not be enough.
She pulled out an article regarding
the plastic surgery and uh,
she says, what do you think of this?
I looked it over and well,
I didn't think it was a good idea,
but she said, hey, why
don't you think about this?
This might be a good thing that
will allow you to stay here.
So the idea would be that he, you know,
have his eyes doubled
or something like that,
a plastic surgery procedure where
you put a fold in the eyelid,
so you look more white, less Japanese.
Then she says, do you think at
work? And I said, I don't know.
Well, she says, shall we look into it?
And um, why is that? Then
Ma'am got anything to lose?
So we decided to try it.
[inaudible]
so Fred gets into his car and he drives
into the city, into San Francisco,
and he just stops in front
of the doctor's office
and he starts pacing, walking
up the steps of this victory
Korean, and then
walking down the steps to leave
thinking this was a really crummy idea.
And then walking back up the steps
thinking, well yeah, maybe I just right,
it's a good idea. And the down the
steps, this is a ridiculous idea.
Giving some doctor your hard
earned money to change your face.
So he goes up and down and up
and down and up and down until
you decided to just
go in and have the procedure done.
He really did it as a way to protect
them as they try to leave the state.
The doctor said he was going to work
on his eyes and then also fix a broken
nose.
I had a broken nose from playing
football and I never had it fixed and um,
said he could do pretty good work on me,
but it turned out he didn't do
everything he said he would.
Well you just took my money.
That's what it was. I actually,
there wasn't anything change except
I didn't have a broken nose anymore.
So he drives back to the East Bay
with a new nose, but the same eyes.
And shortly after that day
at the doctor's office,
he's out buying cigarettes at
a convenience store and a clerk
recognized him and reported him.
And one day walking down the street
was stopped and arrested,
um,
and spent his memorial day in
1942 in the San Leandro jail.
When we got caught, they
called her into yeah.
And um,
I seen the police chief talking
to her for quite a while.
I imagine it's a small jail
and he's just been admitted.
So He's sitting in the lobby and he
sees Ida come in to the front desk.
Wow.
He's just out of earshot. He can't
make out exactly what they're saying,
but at a certain point
they stopped talking
and she just walks out.
So that was the end of it.
I never did see her again.
[inaudible]
he never saw each other again.
So he's sitting there alone in the
San Leandro jail and they ended up
transferring him to Oakland
jail for some reason.
And then he ends up at the federal prison
in San Francisco because resisting the
order was a federal offense.
Anyway. Um,
one day I got a call from the guard
and told me I had a visitor and I
didn't know who it was. You know,
I knew all my friends were in
Kane or they were in the military.
Fred goes down to the visiting room
anyway, and there's this man there.
Hi, I'm a New Yorker.
Hello.
I believe in civil liberties and when
the right of people is being denied,
this is something that
I'm concerned about.
The man says his name is
Ernest [inaudible], and then
he was a very nice foul,
easy to talk to.
You ask me if I need some cigarettes
or something like that, you know,
just to break the ice.
By the way, I asked him,
who do you represent? And
earnest responds, well
[inaudible] and I thought it was maybe
one church or something like that.
See,
we have no way of knowing what exactly
was said between Fred and Ernest
[inaudible]. Both men have passed away,
but it seems like something important
must have happened in this conversation
because if, as Laurie Banai says,
I don't think he had the words
for it that we might have today.
Fred didn't have.
People would think the language
of resistance before this moment.
Something in that conversation must
have given it to him because when Ernest
Bassett asked him, do you want me
to represent you in a court of law?
Fred says, yes.
What do you imagine the words were that
might've turned him in that moment?
I imagine that best seg
must've said to Fred,
we think that what's happened to
Japanese Americans is unconstitutional.
We'd like to bring a lawsuit to say the
Japanese Americans are being sent away
only because of their race. And in that
he gave Fred language.
I think Fred knew what's wrong.
[inaudible]
basic tried to get Fred out of jail,
but the military stepped in and said
he had to join his family and camp.
They were at a place called
tamper and racetracks.
It was a temporary holding spot.
So that meant that the first place that
Fred went after jail was a converted
horse stall.
I opened the door and uh, there's
gapping holes on the walls.
The wind just blew in there. The
desk blew in there and everything.
And this was a small horse doll
because Fred had asked for his own,
you wanted to sit and think
about what to say to his family.
We're also at Tam Fran.
He sat and looked at the single loan
bare light bulb above and the smell of
manure and hey,
I mean it's made for horses,
not for human beings.
[inaudible]
and then all of a sudden I hear a
knock on the door and I opened it.
It was my brother. He says,
Hey, you can't stay here. You,
you gotta come and see the pokes.
[inaudible]
so we walked spread over to the
store where his family's been living
and I was surprised the way
they fixed up their style.
They filled up all the cracks and they
put newspaper photo wall papered it all
up.
This was a common thing
for these families.
Thousands of them were transferred to
more permanent camps and many stayed there
for up to three years. Over time,
the community kind of tried
to build lives for themselves.
You hear stories and see pictures of
people building small Japanese gardens out
of what they found in the area.
He saw newsreels about the
people who made the desert bloom.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
we eventually saw people forming,
you know, baseball teams.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
yeah, my brother,
he was involved in various
Japanese activities and uh,
he thought it might be a good idea for
me to get some suggestions and opinions
regarding to, uh, if I
should find the case or not.
So Fred's brother calls a meeting,
he got about 30 young people together,
I imagine it was like in a mess
hall or something like that.
And they discussed Fred's case.
They were discussion at to themselves
or little groups and I stood around and
waited for someone to speak,
but no one actually
came up to speak to me.
I can see Fred kind of standing in a
corner as people are gathered in small
groups whispering to each other,
stealing glances at them,
but no one says a word to him.
Uh,
finally one day. And you said Fred, uh,
were undecided on if I should fight the
case or not because they didn't want to
make any more disturbance.
Okay.
Anything to upset the parents right at
this time because they were too upset
already and being just being an end cap.
They told them their parents
had been through enough,
leaving their lives behind.
Basically they said,
we can't help you,
but there was one Japanese American group
that did decide to say something about
Fred's case.
What's the name of the
group? J a. C L. Ernest
spastic had a nickname for this group,
the Japanese American Citizens League,
the Jackal's I met,
who is the leadership of
that group? Several of them.
I urge them to oppose the exclusion,
but they didn't seem to be
particularly interested.
The JACL condemned Fred's case and anyone
else who fought against the government
orders said it would not support any of
these individuals who were fighting the
orders and called them
self-styled martyrs. Wow.
They use that phrase. Yes.
They would basically get
everyone else into trouble
to do this by myself.
I just wonder if I was doing wrong
or maybe putting them in shame by,
uh, bringing the issue up again. Uh,
because of Japanese people, they,
they're peaceful people and they,
they like to leave things alone if they
can because they were in enough trouble
as it is because of this Pearl Harbor
attack and the country blame them.
And so they had this sort of
a guilty complex, even though,
uh, they had nothing to do with it.
Majority, I'm just avoided me. So
therefore, I, uh, assume that, uh,
uh,
[inaudible]
that
I got myself in this problem and, uh,
therefore it was my
problem and not theirs.
[inaudible]
Fred continued to fight his case.
He argued that basically rounding
up thousands of Japanese Americans,
American citizens without a
trial, without due process,
basically amounted to
racial discrimination.
His case made its way up and
down the courts. And eventually,
two and a half years after he'd met
Ernest Basset in that jail cell,
the case arrives at the Supreme Court.
You, he, he thought that by the time
his case got to the Supreme Court,
that's Fred's daughter care. And again,
he would be able to vindicate his
family and everyone that had been
incarcerated, right? I mean, that's how
much he believed in the Supreme Court.
And so when, when that didn't happen,
he felt like if he felt
like it was his fault,
yeah,
that's a big burden to carry around.
What ends up happening
is on December 18th,
1944 the supreme court ruled against Fred.
It's kind of a complicated decision.
The Supreme Court said racial distinctions
when the government is making racial
distinction, it's serious. We need
to look at this very, very carefully.
And that was a big precedent.
So in a lot of ways it's kind of a
victory for people fighting racial
discrimination. But then the
court turned around and said,
even though racial
distinctions are serious,
this one is not strictly racial.
We're at war with the Japanese empire.
Therefore rounding up Japanese American
citizens is a way to defend the nation.
Kind. A few, Fred,
at this point like it sounds like it
sounds like lonelier than I can almost
imagine because you're, you're by
yourself pretty much on all fronts,
the country that you feel.
So a part of that you want to actually
enlist in the military to fight for
doesn't seem to want you at that moment.
Your own community
doesn't seem to want you.
Your family is ashamed by you.
Your girlfriend is gone.
[inaudible]
I can't imagine being
more alone at this point.
And he never shared that with my brother
or I, he shared it with my mother, but,
but we didn't, that wasn't part
of our dinner conversation.
[inaudible]
they're discussing drafting a proposal
to reinstate a registry for immigrants
from Muslim countries and perfectly
perfectly honestly say it'll hold
constitutional muster. We did it
during World War II with Japanese,
which you know, call what you will.
Maybe you ban. We're not proposing.
We go back to the days of
internment camps. I go, no, no, no.
I'm not proposing that at all, Megan.
But what I am saying we
need to protect America.
That's the kind of stuff that
gets people scare Carl. Right.
But I'm just saying there is precedent
for it and I'm not saying I agree with
it.
This is the crazy thing about
the core Matson decision.
It is still on the books.
That Guy Carl Higbee got on Megan Kelly
and said this stuff about Korematsu and
the very next day he got on
and apologize for saying that,
but he's right core Matsu is
technically still good law.
Justice Antonin Scalia one said that,
sure core Matsu was wrongly decided,
but if you think that it's not going to
happen again, you're kidding yourself.
The court isn't going to get this across
the precedent in international American
say.
Would you like it too? Um, I think so. Um,
would you like it to know
that's not entered in school yet?
It's a judge named Richard Posner and
at the time the Ellie talked to him,
he was on the Seventh Circuit Court of
Appeals and he was widely considered by
people on both the left and the right
to be one of the most influential judges
in the country.
He sometimes called the 10 Supreme Court
justice and he's a big defender of the
Korematsu decision.
What do you say then to Fred
Komatsu? What do you say then to,
to a Japanese American about
kind of the law and the court?
Well, they were given compensation.
Right. I mean there's, there's,
you know, the, there is, you know,
pain and suffering there is
there, there is an anguish, right,
that we can't exactly commodify.
Uh, yeah. But um,
at the time it all happened
shortly after Pearl Harbor.
It seemed like the right thing to do and
it probably was the right thing to do.
And I imagine that the officials
and federal government,
and I'm 1941,
they probably didn't know anything about
Japanese Americans on the west coast.
I think Roosevelt had ever met a Japanese
American. Right. Doubt it. Right.
Thanks for that. You know,
the fact that he hadn't ever met anybody
might've been a reason for him to be
more restrained in his
executive orders, right?
No, because all he cares about is
the defense of the United States.
If there's any possibility of Japanese
American somehow cooperating with the
invasion force,
then he has to move the Japanese
Americans. That's, that's,
I'm sure that's all he
would've thought of. Right.
I mean I think it's all he did think of,
but what else could he have thought of?
That's the only thing
he is going to focus on.
And if he does and he could be impeached.
Well he could also worry about
citizens. Right. And I think one of the,
no, no, no, no. Look you're not.
You're missing the priorities.
The priority is defense.
That's the priority. That's what
these people are thinking about.
You think they have time
to be thinking about any,
any kind of Nice ideas for protecting
people any more than than Lincoln did.
What he's referring to,
there is a moment in 1861 when Abraham
Lincoln basically tossed this alleged
confederate in jail without due process
and then justified it by saying he had
to save the Union and that
case Supreme Court justice,
Roger Tani ruled against
him, should legal said,
oh well Tani he's the chief justice.
And he said this jerk should be
released. I guess I have to do that.
Here's the chief justice. No,
you do that enough times as
the president you're out.
It seems to me that that's why we
have courts. We have, oh, come on.
What's the restrain the executives use?
Why do we have,
we do not have courts so that presidents
can be checked in situations of a
national emergency. That
was my courts were set up.
So that then what I mean, I guess I'm,
I'm flailing now, but then
what stops them? What if,
cause if Congress can't stop them
and if the courts can't stop them,
like what can stop a
president in a time of war?
There's nobody. There's
nobody can check that.
That's the presidents responsibility.
[inaudible]
obviously I like a do over because
somehow in the heat of the moment,
I forgot that I'm talking about
defending the rights of actual American
citizens.
And Posner is talking about people
who are rebels to the country.
Um, there's probably a way where I
could have said pointed that out to him.
Um, in terms of the court
stepping in, I mean, it happens,
it happened to Truman. But you know,
judge Posner is right that
it doesn't happen a lot,
which is why he gets to be judge Posner.
And I'm the guy that
had to check Wikipedia.
And by the way,
do you think these supreme court
justices are great big brains,
big stars who were selected because of
the best lawyers in the United States and
their decisions
are, are usually great. You
think all of that? I don't,
I don't have a high respect
for the Supreme Court at all.
Um, I'm, I mean, you
look at their decisions
[inaudible]
you look at them how they're
pointed, who appoints them,
right. This is,
so why do you think the supreme court
has such a great balance to the president
in a war?
[inaudible]
but this is what gets me up and gets me
going because I still think it can be
used as a precedent. So
you're, you're, you're, you're,
you're still worried that it
can be used. Yes. And that,
do you think it will be like,
do you felt like, you know,
I think we cannot take this for granted.
[inaudible]
coming up
since Fred Korematsu couldn't get
justice inside Supreme Court question is,
can you find it on the outside
more? Perfect. We'll continue in a second.
I'm Preet Bharara every
weekend. My podcast, stay tuned.
I answer your questions about what's
really happening in Washington.
I wonder if it is legal for president
Trump to initiate military action against
North Korea. What happens
if Mueller returns?
I'm indictment again, the
president. I just want to know,
are you a table genius?
Subscribe to stay tuned
from cafe and W NYC studios.
This is more perfect. I'm Chad. I'm rod
here with Julia Longoria. All right,
so getting back to the story of Fred,
uh, picking up from the decision.
What happened after that?
So the interment camp where
Fred was staying closed in 1945,
um,
and Fred had gotten permission by that
point to work at a steel mill in Detroit.
So he was living in Detroit. He fell
in love with a woman named Catherine.
They got married, moved back to
the bay area and had two kids.
And Karen,
his daughter says that they were kind
of ostracized from the Japanese American
community. They grew up outside
of the Japanese community.
He was involved in boy scouts, girl
scouts. So I was at girl scouts.
So you know, the camps, when we had to
open the camp, it would work on that. Uh,
the Presbyterian church in Oakland
and then he became an elder.
So even joined the lion's club
and he was president twice.
And Karen says throughout the
forties, the 50s, the 60s,
she never heard him talk about
his case. No, never. No, never.
He just, he never, he never,
he never told a story even after she
confronted him about it in high school.
Yeah, it's, that's it.
But she says in like 1969 ish,
68 or 69 when the world was
in a very different place.
They got a phone call back
in those days, you know, you,
my parent's phone number was in
the phone book of all things.
Cause I mean my father would get phone
calls from law students want to interview
him, but he really didn't want to
talk about his case much. He just,
it was just too painful.
But this time there was a professor
on the line from the University of
California, Berkeley. He was a Japanese
guy actually, and he told Fred,
I really, really want you
to come into my class.
There was a ethnic studies class
that was actually off campus.
Ethnic studies was not even
recognized then. So he,
he talked at this ethnic studies
class and these kids were brutal.
I mean UC Berkeley at that
time had this, you know,
notorious reputation
of being very radical.
People were asking questions during
the whole hour. This is Jean Kwan,
former mayor of Oakland. She
was in the class that day.
It was a important time that you,
at different times of your life you
had to learn to stand up to authority.
And certainly these students who are like,
you know, fist pounding saying, well,
why didn't you, why didn't you
protest? Why didn't you do this?
Why didn't you do that? Why didn't you
fight harder? And we're almost, you know,
angry that he wasn't angry. You know,
I think you've got to remember that a
lot of these students even know anything
about the camps. Many,
many kids had not had frank
discussions with their own parents.
So of course Matsui was probably a
surrogate for like their parents.
How could they have gone through that and
never told me they had no right not to
tell me and so they're really angry
at their parents surrogate or not.
Fred felt like he was being
indicted all over again.
It was such a painful
experience for my father.
He never wanted to speak to anyone again.
Fred would ultimately
challenge his conviction in a
lower court and he would win
the Supreme Court decision still stands,
but he was able to clear
his own personal name
[inaudible]
and in around 1990 again the
world in a very different place.
He finds himself again
on a college campus.
This time the University of of Michigan,
my father and mother were walking with
some other students across the campus to
see the newly renovated
library and you know,
my father loved architecture. It
was very old gothic a library.
So they're walking through this sort of
open quad looking the architecture and
then they come upon
this group of students,
a group of Arab American students.
The students start walking toward him.
They all of a sudden kind of surrounded
my father and they had this certificate,
um, to give to my father, to
thank him for speaking up.
So that was meaningful to him.
Why, why did that make you
emotional? Why that story
[inaudible]
Oh, uh, well
because it, it meant so much to my father
that this group really honored him
that also had been racially profiled,
you know,
to think that he would be
able to touch their lives.
It kind of reinforced what he was doing.
[inaudible]
do you have the same faith in the
Constitution that your dad did that? Yes,
I have great faith in our constitution.
It's a great document.
It is so happens though that it's the
way that certain people interpret it that
gets us into trouble. Yes, definitely.
Okay.
[inaudible] Julie Envoy
[inaudible] this from
our legal editor, Allianz
[inaudible]. The danger is
the law, the need for my
travel ban 3.0 coming here tonight.
The top administration unveiling new
travel restrictions on certain foreign
nationals from eight countries
where they're gonna go,
because they sold everything with the
feeling where they're thinking they're
going to start a new
life in United States.
[inaudible] this is the one we won. We
won the freedom we want to deliver to
people. We are the people, we
the people. But there are many,
many lawyers here. They're
all working pro bono.
They're from different organizations
is what resistance looks like.
This sends a message that they cannot
do away with constitutional protections
without people standing
up for the constitution.
So I think this is inspirational.
I think it's wonderful,
and I think we need to be
vigilant and keep fighting.